the state department could be close to a
deal to secure the release of wnba star
brittany griner and marine veteran paul
whelan from captivity in russia now
there is speculation that it may involve
in exchange for one of the world's most
notorious arms dealer his name is victor
boot he's now in u.s custody for
conspiring to support terrorism and
conspiring to kill americans christina
raffini is following this story for us
bringing people home
bringing britney home bringing paul home
this is something that we're focused on
24 7. secretary of state anthony blinken
said his department laid out a
substantial proposal to moscow weeks ago
but would not say if progress has been
made
this as detained wnba star brittany
griner testified for the first time
wednesday since she was jailed on drug
charges i did not plan
or have the intent to bring any cannabis
or
banned substance to russia greiner has
pleaded guilty and faces up to 10 years
in prison but said she brought
prescription marijuana cartridges into
the country by accident and claimed
she'd been forced to sign legal
documents she didn't understand we had
to use my phone for google translate for
him to be able to tell me a little bit i
didn't know exactly what i was saying my
rights were never read to me
no one explained
any of it to me bg is probably the
strongest person that i know earlier
this month cbs news spoke to griner's
wife sherelle who at the time said she
didn't feel the government was doing
enough being quiet they are not moving
they are not doing anything and so
my wife is struggling but yesterday's
announcement marked a departure from the
usual quiet diplomacy of hostage
negotiation i would tell you that
the offer has been
been made
and and
we certainly hope that that russia will
favorably engage on it administration
officials would not respond to reports
that the offer on the table includes a
potential prisoner swap for the infamous
international arms dealer victor boots a
russian national serving a 25-year
prison sentence in the u.s boot earned
the nickname merchant of death for his
alleged role in providing weapons that
fueled deadly conflicts across africa he
oversaw operations capable of delivering
enough weapons to launch rebellions fuel
revolutions and slaughter untold
thousands of people
he was an accessory to violence on a
scale that is beyond comprehension
now until recently state and doj sources
told cbs news boot was not on the table
he took years to catch and he was simply
too big of a get to give up so if this
is true clearly that calculation has
changed now we should note that whelan
was convicted in 2020 on espionage
espionage charges which he has denied a
lawyer for victor boot would not say if
his client is part of the deal and the
kremlin says no deal has been made but
negotiations are ongoing of course boot
has long maintained his innocence
regarding the charges against him yeah
the nickname merchant of death doesn't
sound so great i would imagine some
people would say that's not a fair swap
but if it was your family member i would
be thinking
and that's always the calculation the
families want them to do anything to get
their loved ones out and then there's
national security implications if they
release somebody like this
we'll continue that conversation thank
you christina